this video is brought to you by
innovative language the creators of
norwegian class 101 and danish class 101
innovative language courses are one of
my favorite ways to start learning a new
language online
click the link in the description for a
free lifetime account to give it a try
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is
johnson today we're going to compare
danish and norwegian specifically one of
the two official forms of norwegian
buk maul due to the union of denmark and
norway which lasted for centuries
mall is largely based on the danish
spoken by the upper classes in norway
during that time
danish and buk mal are in large part the
same with some slight differences in
grammar and spelling
some different vocabulary words and
usage and more than anything else
differences in pronunciation danish is
famous for being difficult to understand
because of the tendency to slur and
delete sounds that are more clearly
pronounced in norwegian
to be clear norwegian has no official
pronunciation
and all accents are considered correct
but the pronunciation
the accent of the capital oslo serves as
a de facto standard
let's compare some basic vocabulary and
see where the differences lie
especially in pronunciation in norwegian
we have this word
meaning weird or funny in danish
means pleasant also notice the
difference in the r
sound in norwegian it's an alveolar
trill
in danish it's a uvular fricative or
approximant at the beginning of the word
and at the end of the word it's silent
but in its place we can hear
the glottal stop or creaky voice that
appears in some danish words
it's represented in ipa transcription by
this symbol
norwegian doesn't have this feature but
instead has distinctions in pitch accent
both of these words mean knife knee
in both words the combination k n is
pronounced the same
but in norwegian iv is pronounced eve
while in danish it's a diphthong and
again the word ends in a glottal stop or
laryngeal
creaky voice these words mean dress
there's a subtle difference in the sound
that kj represents in either language in
norwegian
it's a voiceless palatal fricative
while in danish it's in danish it's a
cluster of two sounds
k followed by because the second sound
is palatal
it ends up sounding somewhat similar to
the norwegian sound which is also
palatal
these words mean deer in norwegian
and in danish notice the difference in
the initial consonant
in danish k and g can appear before a
front vowel
but in norwegian they can't so the
digraphs gj
and kj are used to represent the
different consonant sounds
also notice the silent r in the danish
word
these words mean shirt in norwegian
and in danish again notice the
difference in the initial consonant
this time represented by skj in
norwegian
it's while in danish it's
there's also a difference in the vowel
sound in norwegian it's more like
while in danish it's more like or
because the danish r
after a vowel is pronounced as a vowel
itself
these words mean ship in norwegian
and in danish notice that in the
norwegian word
sk represents while in the danish word
it represents
sk silent g occurs in both languages
sometimes in the same contexts and
sometimes in different contexts
these two words are cognates and both
feature a silent g
in norwegian meaning delicious or lovely
and in danish daily meaning wonderful or
lovely
and sometimes delicious also notice the
slightly different spelling
there are lots of little spelling
differences like this between danish and
norwegian
while delicious is a primary meaning of
the norwegian word
in danish its more common meaning is
wonderful or lovely
these words mean book in norwegian
[Music]
and in danish notice the final k in the
norwegian word
and the g in the danish word in danish
the final g
is silent the vowel represented by o
is also different in norwegian it's more
like u
while in danish it's more like o but
here the omg together
actually form a diphthong these words
mean guest
or visitor in norwegian yes
and in danish yes notice the difference
at the beginning of the words
in norwegian g is silent before j so
it's simply
ye while in danish it's ge like i said
before
in danish ga can come before a front
vowel but in norwegian it can't
these words mean evening in norwegian
and in danish in norwegian
often is also used but it's less
commonly used than
kvel and a little more old-fashioned and
in danish a cognate of the norwegian
word exists
but it's old-fashioned and not used much
anymore
these words mean page or side in
norwegian
seed and in danish see
while these words look the same on paper
the danish pronunciation has the soft
d and the final vowel vanishes see
now let's look at some sentences in both
languages and see how different they are
if you've seen my previous video on
norwegian you may recognize these
sentences
these sentences mean i want to eat in
norwegian
and in danish yeah here we can see two
sentences that are identical on paper
of course there are some slight
differences in pronunciation but nothing
really worth pointing out
here's another sentence meaning i
haven't eaten anything today
in norwegian and in danish
yeah especially here's another sentence
that's very similar on paper
with some differences in pronunciation
and one word with a slightly different
form in either language
in norwegian there's no the neutral
singular
of in danish there's the neutral
singular of
notice how the negation word is
pronounced differently in either
language
in norwegian and in danish
in norwegian the double k represents a
long consonant
in danish are voiced when doubled
the double letter does not indicate a
long consonant in danish
also notice the difference in
pronunciation of this word
in norwegian and in danish
in norwegian the long a vowel is
pronounced ah
while in danish it's pronounced a and in
norwegian the g
is pronounced as while in danish a final
g like this
is silent or an approximant that's
almost
silent like a slight r sound
another sentence meaning they like to
drive fast cars
in norwegian d-league
first notice the different ways of
expressing like in the two languages
in norwegian there's in danish
like is expressed with the phrase kunali
why does it include kuna which means can
or able to
well even though now the whole phrase
just means like
it originated with the meaning of able
to bear something
meaning you're able to handle it or deal
with it like it's
not too bad next notice the different
form of the infinitive particle
like two in english and notice the
different spelling and pronunciation of
the verb
meaning to drive
next we see different adjectives meaning
fast in norwegian
and in danish woody the word
does exist in danish but it's very
old-fashioned to use it with the meaning
of fast
but it's still often used with the
meaning of healthy
also exists in norwegian as a synonym of
rask
another sentence meaning crime is
increasing due to high unemployment
in norwegian criminals
and in danish criminality
the main difference in this pair of
sentences is a difference in vocabulary
preference
for example these words which are the
present tense forms of the verbs meaning
to increase there is a cognate of
in danish is but the usual word would be
stir and there's a cognate of stia
in norwegian
we see basically the same phrase meaning
due to
literally on ground of ground as in
reason
but there's a difference in
pronunciation between these words here
in norwegian and in danish
in the norwegian word the u represents
an u
sound but in danish the u can be
pronounced differently after the uvular
r more like o and while the norwegian
word ends in a long consonant
the danish word ends in followed by a
glottal stop or creaky voice
the d is silent after n in this word the
f
is silent and at the end of the danish
word for unemployment
there's a soft d let's examine
one final pair of sentences these
sentences mean falling in love is common
among young people
in norwegian
in this last pair of sentences again we
see the same sentence structure with
some different vocabulary preference
the words for common are different
notice the different spellings of the
words meaning
among blunt but again
d is silent after n so we don't really
hear a difference in the consonants here
the main difference here is in the
quality of the a vowel
notice that the terms for young people
are somewhat different
there is a word for young people in
danish that's more similar to the
norwegian one
though that word is pretty old-fashioned
in danish
as you can see norwegian and danish are
very similar on paper but end up
sounding quite different when they're
spoken
they're different enough to be
considered different languages but
they're close enough that speakers of
either language can read the other one
without much trouble
it seems to me that speakers of either
language could learn to understand the
other one as it's naturally spoken
by learning the features of the other
language's phonology and then getting
lots of exposure to it
indeed people who move from one country
to the other do just that and also learn
to make their own speech more
intelligible to speakers of the other
language
by speaking more clearly or more slowly
but a lot of norwegians and danes as
well as swedes tell me that they just
speak english with each other instead
and that brings me to the question of
the day to speakers of norwegian and
danish
and swedes too if you want to jump in do
you think learning to understand each
other and communicate in your respective
languages is a useful skill
or do you think it's better to simply
use english as many people do
and other people what do you think about
the differences between danish and buk
maul
do they genuinely seem like different
languages to you
if you're excited to learn more
norwegian or danish then check out
langfocus.com
norwegian class or langfocus.com
danish class innovative language courses
are among the most popular
online courses in the world and for good
reason they're very extensive courses
with literally hundreds of lessons for
learners of any level
their core feature is podcast style
audio lessons
which is great for people who like to
learn using audio materials and for
people who want to learn on the go
i'm a member of several class 101 and
pod 101 courses
and i use them to improve my listening
comprehension and to improve my
pronunciation through shadowing the
dialogues and monologues
but class 101 and pod 101 courses offer
more than just audio lessons
they also have lots of video lessons and
excellent tools like downloadable
transcripts and lesson
notes spaced repetition flash cards and
quizzes
features like these help you to review
and solidify what you learn in each
lesson so that you keep building upon
what you've learned and create a strong
foundation in the language
class 101 and pod 101 lessons are
compact and easy to complete in a single
sitting
but don't just move on to the next
lesson and forget about the previous one
the review tools are there to help
solidify what you've learned
it would be a mistake to breeze through
all the lessons too quickly without
using all of those extra review features
i've never learned a language using only
an innovative language course
but i'm a member of several of their
sites and i regularly use them as part
of my study program
lots of content is free including all
new lessons which are free for the first
couple of weeks
and then if you want access to all the
archived content you can upgrade to a
paid account
i really recommend you check out
innovative language courses
whether for norwegian danish or one of
32 other languages they offer
click the link in the description to get
a free lifetime account
i also want to give a big shout out to
all the langfocus patreon supporters
especially the top tier patrons whose
names are on the screen
check out patreon.com langfocus and
check out the benefits of the various
tiers
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you